I just wanted you didn't know when we  hold hands I may look like this on the  outside but I feel like this on the  inside  [Music]  it's me good advice cupcake when moving  through life it's really important to  have a plan okay here's my plan  [Music]  it's me good a nice cupcake sometimes  you have all the ingredients in your  fridge to make a five-star restaurant  quality wheel but you just don't feel  like cooking so why spend hours cooking  when you can embrace it good advice  I don't feel so good it's me  good advice cupcake sometimes you may  find yourself having a friend love you  just try some of my fresh butter it  turns out to be made  well you know what you should do bye I  didn't even like you anyway yeah so this  is your internal dialogue speaking you  should know you are doing a job at  everything that's not true you are  amazing you are you look like crap  they like you better if sometimes your  worst hater is yourself junk that [ __ ]  [Music]